sévère 14h55 que le Canada a franchi le
cap des 40 millions d'habitants il est
très probable que cette personne ce 40
millionième Canadiens soit un immigrant
car c'est l'immigration qui contribue
très largement à la croissance
démographique du pays et ce un rythme
record c'est un rythme de croissance
rapide il y a peu de pays en fait dans
l'ensemble du monde qui présente des
taux de croissance démographique
supérieures à 2,7 mais la croissance de
la population n'est pas la même partout
on voit bien que des transformations le
considérables en 1950 le Québec
représentait 29% de la population au
pays alors qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est que
22%. à l'opposé les provinces de l'Ouest
et l'Ontario n'ont cessé de voir leur
proportion augmenter depuis plus de 50
ans
l'Ontario accueille à peu près plus de
la moitié des immigrants qui viennent
s'installer au Canada et avec le poids
démographique vient le poids politique
soit le nombre de sièges à la Chambre
des communes qui sait aussi accrue la
dernière fois c'est 308 à 338 et c'était
des sièges qui ont été principalement
distribués donc en Ontario dans l'Ouest
alors que le gouvernement fédéral compte
maintenir la cadence de l'immigration
dans les prochaines années
certains questionnent la capacité
d'accueil et d'intégration on peut pas
simplement continuer à augmenter la
population attirer plus d'immigrants
sans être prêt sur le plan du logement
sur le plan des services de la santé
est-ce qu'on a la capacité pour on n'a
jamais mesuré sans parler de la
francisation les consultations sur les
migrations au Québec prévues à l'automne
prochain arrive à point nommer croix
Richard Marcoux il faut vraiment qu'on
ait cette discussion là à savoir vers
quoi on peut orienter en quelque sorte
nos politiques de façon à pouvoir oui
maintenir le pot du Québec mais en tout
cas s'assurer du CE français parce que
l'échelle du pays Statistique Canada
prévoit que le prochain cap celui des 50
millions d'habitants sera franchi d'ici
20 ans ici Jacques Aurélie Charbonneau
Radio-Canada montré